you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
500 game against a magical world
let's try c4 all righty all right Knight
c3 retains some flexibility with my
center pawns a hedgehog let's see if
black goes for a fee and head on now
let's break up that pawn duo and strike
at it right away
all right let's castle and then we're
gonna go it's my dark square bishop
let's uh let's strike at the c5 pond
with this c4 Knight G 494 Bishop f4 I'm
not sure
I may just take and try to hang on to
that
so what to do okay this was my idea so
maybe he's misplaced slightly do you
five is a little bit weakened can I not
just take care
I'm gonna grab on c3 d4 d5 is hit twice
alright so I have the bishop hair I'm up
upon and maybe I could still track down
another I want to move my knight
soon we're too I could always defend
this pawn with Bishop d6 hmm let's start
with rook to be one that's what my
instincts tell me just put a rock on a
half-open file but
there's something else should I stop the
clean from even getting active maybe
that's an idea
let's go Queen a4 interfere with one of
the developing moves black may have so
how they getting the pawn back how would
they dislodge my bishop once he's on d6
snipe I don't want to invest some move
with kicking the night away I think I'm
fine with I think I can tolerate a
knight in my position so I'm just sort
of viewing this as the knight being out
of play on g4 some concern maybe if you
know there was some more pressure
against f2 but that's not quite what
we're working with here
b2 would be pretty difficult to defend I
have this square under control
let's go here Queen is now restricted
and it seems pretty sensible as well
rook up to D 1 and this point will be a
little bit more sensitive when I do that
but I don't see any issue with it maybe
I should have gone for this first hmm
all right there being a bit of a past
let's let's go here go with the other
Brook the Knights they can't if I cannot
make use of e5 I have this possibly I
get interfere with the Queen's defense
on a d4 push also my queen let's keep in
mind has some lateral influence so maybe
I could pick up that night one day
Queen's in a good spot already well hmm
if I play c4 there's d4 can I just go
straight in for like a building up type
idea just doubling rooks on the D file
and really trying to smash through at
that center point let's give it a shot
got all my pieces working now that guy
still needs to contribute it's a little
bit of a clock edge and this is a
blunder because I could take here I'm on
the Queen oh no no it's yet as a blunder
no it's not my queens are protected hmm
but but but I believe I can take the
bishop with my queen here and enter a
two bishops versus rook and balanced in
the game
yeah I think I have that
and just
checking for maybe something better
Queen takes Queen Knight takes Queen
Bishop takes Bishop there's rook takes
I think I'm gonna try this one you know
tonight has to recapture two bishops
versus a rook they can test the D file
that'll drop the e pawn
and this guy if the beef ha never falls
this will be I don't think they'll be
very many more moves to the game so I
should probably just get on with pushing
he's passed and he could be supported
with the bishop I could even go for this
and control the promotion Square keep on
pushing and h6 I'll do this just to
secure my bishop okay maybe I should
break down this structure yeah oh okay
all right let's let's run it like this
Bishop here so I could push my pawn and
then get my Bishop here f4 and then I'll
have a lock down on the position I'll
have very good security with my pieces
so f4 the threat one of many around this
point is Bishop to d5 yeah King can't
even scoot over I got this square
covered you know hmm maybe maybe block
was too fast with this Knight to g4 idea
Knight turning out to be a bit a bit
misplaced on g4
I think c4 was a move and reply to my
Bishop e3 and then I have to move my
Bishop again so they're down to a minute
all right so they're going to grab some
material
oh you know what on that rook move I had
rook there
No
alright let's just insert this Chuck and
then secure my Bishop King up here to
scoop up the pond many different
approaches I'm just trying to take one
where there's good coordination
now let's see what's simplest probably
just capture yeah I'm fine with that
yeah let's just take I guess we're gonna
get one of my pawns no check
I'm fine with stepping up and then
planking to f3 I have this covered so I
don't have to pull my bishop off of this
diagonal and probably just advance rook
here scoop up that a pawn and defend my
a pond yeah they'll probably resign
somewhere right around here let's scoop
up a pond you know got a piece a couple
pawns more active rook okay I'll play it
out for a little bit maybe till mate you
know stalemates I don't need my king his
endgame down to 15 I guess here and now
I could get pushing my a pond plenty of
time to finish this one off
they're a seven and then pushed through
threatening mate okay they resigned
okay um what to say about this one
yeah it really came down to well I'm
probably too quick to think that this is
the issue this Knight to g4 move but
right around here there are other other
options like c4 I think going for a
structural change and in reply to that I
believe you post right up in the center
and release this bishop immediately
target the d5 pawn on takes I believe
this falls so
I think that this is a move hmm what
else can black do so I am threatening to
take you know so I think this is the
move on captures I'm fine with this and
then I could try to play against the
isolated pawn I guess this is the other
main decision c4 here well I don't know
if I should say other main decision but
we'll have a look and see about this
Knight to g4 move because after this
here in Bishop f6 I could I could get
away with taking that punt and that's so
easy to track down Queen goes over here
trying this uh you know just quick
developing active like move another pawn
Falls so maybe maybe capture here but
now I really don't like the Knight to g4
move I mean maybe the move is c4 here
we'll have a look at what the computer
at that point but right around here I
think I maintain control maybe this was
more to the point immediately going
opposite and looking for these ideas but
I could I could afford to go to B 1 and
then to d1 and I think the simple in an
effective plan here of doubling rooks is
is fine here here and we'll see this
must be just winning now for me I almost
I almost overlooked that my queen was
hanging yeah you always have to be
careful in situations like these were
that the Queen's are opposite each other
and you know if to be careful of you
know if I'm doing a move like this
there's always this Knight takes Knight
and then a knight recapture
taking advantage of the unprotected
queen but yeah 95 and I'm just winning
here don't know if this is best we'll
see with the computer but yeah this is
certainly a one end game to bishops or
too strong and I have a pawn or two
don't know a pawn plus two bishops and
upon versus the rook is really uh no
match see what the graph is saying you
know so right around here for sure
because once Bishop f6 was played yeah
that could capture let's put the arrows
on
once the once this capture was made its
just liking me
so okay Bishop to e6 does it like Knight
to g4 Bishop Bishop to e3 see form okay
so it does like this move and then
Knight to e5 and let's just carry it out
a few more okay Bishop f5 yeah I think
I've played the white end against a
stock fish from this position it's
useful half open file and just see one
Bishop to f4 yeah guess c4 is the
critical move definitely a definitely a
big transition point changing the
structure three versus two now four
black and I guess there's some idea to
undermine this point it should be six to
reinforce here have four mmm
getting pretty sharp committal move
without question some gaps here mmm
I don't know if I'd be a fan of f4 here
but I'd be looking at this kind of stuff
you know with trying to break it c4 you
know okay
well c4 I guess in reply to Bishop III
is much better after Knight g4 in Bishop
f4
can't play Bishop f6 for sure Bishop e6
is another move and then at least on a
capture black is there to recapture and
there is support for this
yeah III a move like this always scares
me some because you know there's no
longer a path back immediately
you know you start to wonder well where
is he gonna go yeah we haven't moved
like h6 and I have to take some steps to
meet the g5 move h4 I guess but now this
night is a bit scary with still many
pieces on board all minor pieces still
on board and if I'm happy if I have to
play h4 just to secure my bishop like
this you know that means I'm not I'm not
able to kick this night away so easily
that concerns me some so the point I'm
getting at here is I don't know if I
would really be leaning towards e3 I may
try to key in on d4 rook to c1 first
with these possibilities but yeah I'd be
a extra hesitant to play e3 here just to
control this square but yeah as a
played-out Knight g4 Bishop f4 and
Bishop f6 is a mistake maybe I don't
know is it chalked up as a blunder was
that the blunder in the game no that
wasn't the blunder the blunder was the
the knight move here so maybe it's just
that was the the mistake in the game
playing Bishop to f6 you know let's see
just I guess the final decision here
does it like this capture and then Queen
takes bishop yeah likes that best two
bishops versus the rook and it's enough
the charts eval okay well interesting
game II
it's a Terra defense classical variation
as usual if you have any feedback feel
free to leave it in the comment section
below and I will catch you in the next
one that's all for now take care bye
you